LAST NIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, COMEY, CLAPPER,
LYNCH, OTHERS MAY HAVE TO
TESTIFY UNDER OATH.
AND TONIGHT DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA MOB ONCE AGAIN, THEY ARE
IN THEIR TYPICAL PSYCHOTIC STATE
OF MANIA AND HYSTERIA ALL
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP DARED TO
CONSULT WITH HIS DOCTORS, MAKE
HIS CHOICE.
I THOUGHT WE WERE PRO-CHOICE.
TALK TO HIS HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND TAKE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AS A
PREVENTATIVE MEASURE AGAINST
COVID-19.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE WORST OF
THE WORST.
BY THE WAY, WE WILL HELP EDUCATE
DR. JOYLESS BEHAR.
DR. LIBERAL JOE AND ALL THE
OTHER PSYCHOPATHS CONSPIRACY
SPIRITIST -- CONSPIRACY AT
MSNBC.
DAY 65 JOE BIDEN HIDING IN HIS
BASEMENT MUMBLING INCOHERENT
THOUGHTS ON HIS DISASTROUS
PODCAST.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WILL JOE
EVER BRAVED THE RURAL WORLD
AGAIN?
HI, JOE, HOW ARE YOU?
WE ARE DOING A PODCAST, THAT
GUY.
A FULL REPORT BUT THE TOP STORY,
WHAT DID BARACK KNOW, WHAT DID
JOE KNOW AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW
IT?
JANUARY 20, 2017, DONALD TRUMP
WAS BEING INAUGURATED AS THE
45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ON THE VERY SAME DATE IN THE
FINAL HOURS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, SUSAN RICE,
REMEMBER HER?
SHE WAS THE WHITE HOUSE, IN THE
WHITE HOUSE CRAFTING AN EMAIL
FROM SUSAN RICE TO SUSAN RICE.
HERSELF.
IN A VERY UNUSUAL LETTER, RICE
WAS MEMORIALIZED WITH THE
MEETING THAT TOOK PLACE 15 DAYS
EARLIER WHEN HER FORMER BOSS,
BARACK GATHERED ALL OF HIS TOP
INTEL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
TOGETHER IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
IN THAT MEETING, BRANDON,
KLAPPER, COMEY, BIDEN, YATES,
RICE, ALL THEY ARE MET, ALL
PRESENT IN THE OVAL OFFICE AND
THEY WERE DISCUSSING A RUSSIAN
COLLUSION IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
TOO BAD THEY DIDN’T KNOW TALK
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON’S BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DISINFORMATION
DOSSIER.
THAT WAS USED.
THE REAL RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
AND ACCORDING TO RICE’S EMAIL
"PRESIDENT OBAMA BEGAN THE
CONVERSATION BY STRESSING HIS
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
THAT EVERY ASPECT OF THIS ISSUE
IS HANDLED BY THE INTELLIGENCE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES."
BY THE BOOK.
OKAY QUESTION WHEN SHE CONTINUED
AND HE REITERATED, "OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TEAM NEEDS TO
PROCEED AS IT NORMALLY WOULD, BY
THE BOOK.
AND IN A PARAGRAPH JUST
DECLASSIFIED BY ACTING DNA
DIRECTOR RIC GRENELL, SUSAN
WRITES WROTE, "DIRECTOR COMEY
CONFIRMED HE IS PROCEEDING BY
THE BOOK."
NOW WHY WOULD SUSAN RICE AND WE
KNOW WHAT A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR
SHE IS, WHY DOES SHE FEEL THE
NEED TO WRITE, BY THE BOOK THREE
TIMES ON THE LAST DATE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IN RELATION TO A
15-DAY-OLD MEETING?
WHY DID SHE DO IT ON THE FINAL
DAY?
OH, LET ME GO BACK COME I FORGOT
TO MEMORIALIZE THAT MEETING FROM
15 DAYS AGO.
ACCORDING TO THE SAME EMAIL,
RICE WROTE, HE HAD NO INDICATION
INCOMING SECURITY ADVISOR FLYNN
HAD PASSED ON ANY CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL TO HIS FUTURE RUSSIAN
COUNTERPARTS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THEY HAD NO
EVIDENCE AT ALL AS
OF JANUARY 4TH.
IT WAS PETER STRZOK AND
JAMES COMEY THAT REOPENED IT.
BY THE WAY THE LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION WAS UNUSUAL BUT IN
REALITY WHAT WAS PARTICULARLY
UNUSUAL COMEY AGGRESSIVE
PERSECUTION OF GENERAL PLAN.
AFTER THAT SO CALLED "BY THE
BOOK" MEETING SALLY GATES AND
JAMES COMEY DECIDED WHITE TO
DISCUSS PLAN.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE RECENTLY
TESTIMONY FROM SALLY YATES, THIS
IS FROM THE HOUSE UNTIL
COMMITTEE THAT THE CREPT
CONGENITAL, COWARDLY, YOU KNOW
ADAM SCHIFF WAS HIDING HERE THE
FORMER DEPUTY AG, SHE ADMITS SHE
WAS SHOCKED TO LEARN.
ON JANUARY 5TH, BARACK OBAMA AND
THE PRESIDENT WITH DETAILS OF
THE WIRETAPPED PHONE CALLS.
DOES THAT SEEM "BY THE BOOK" TO
YOU?
WHAT ABOUT THE FLYNN CASE
DEMANDING TO BE REOPENED JUST
THE DAY BEFORE, JANUARY 4, 2020
AFTER THE INVESTIGATION FOUND NO
EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING?
ONE OTHER FACT ABOUT
JANUARY 5TH.
THE CHIEF OF STAFF OF
BARACK OBAMA, THAT GUY WAS
UNMASKING FLYNN.
DENNIS McDONAGH.
COINCIDENCE?
EIGHT DAYS BEFORE THEY LEFT THE
OVAL OFFICE AND DONALD TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED, THEN JOE BIDEN WHO
SAID ON DAY ONE OF THIS LAST
WEEK, HE DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT UNMASKING.
WE FOUND OUT HE WAS ONE OF THE
ON MASTERS.
WHAT ABOUT COMEY SENDING THE
AGENTS AS HE ADMITS AND BRAGS ON
TAPE TO AMBUSH GENERAL FLYNN A
33 YEAR VETERAN FOUR DAYS INTO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
SOMETHING YOU WOULD NEVER DO GET
AWAY WITH IN ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION?
WHAT ABOUT BEFORE MEETING WITH
THOSE FBI AGENTS, WELL FROM A
GENERAL FLYNN CALLED
ANDREW MCCABE, DEPUTY FBI GUY
AND ASKED HIM, DO I NEED MY LAWY
WHAT ABOUT THE AGENT WHO ASKED
"WHAT IS OUR GOAL WITH GENERAL
FLYNN?
IS IT TO GET HIM TO TELL THE
TRUTH, AND ADMISSION, OR TO GET
HIM TO LIFE SO WE CAN PROSECUTE
HIM OR GET HIM FIRED?"
IS THAT POLICY BY THE FBI, GET
SOMEBODY TO LIE, SAID A PERJURY
TRAP, AMBUSH 8:30 THREE YEAR
VETERAN AND TELL HIM HE DOESN’T
NEED A ATTORNEY WHEN HE DID NEED
ONE?
NONE OF THAT IS BY THE BOOK.
WHAT ABOUT THE TEXT RELATES TO
LISA PAGE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANT TO KNOW
EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING.
THEY WANT TO BE KEPT ABREAST OF
THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOES.
WHAT ABOUT OBSTRUCTION INSURANCE
POLICY IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
DONALD TRUMP WINS?
NOW, IF THERE FBI DIRECTOR RAY,
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH ANY OF
THIS?
ARE YOU?
WILL YOU EVER HOLD ANYONE
ACCOUNTABLE?
DO YOU, DIRECTOR RAY CARE ABOUT
ABUSE OF POWER AND CORRUPTION
THAT TOOK PLACE AT THE WORLD’S
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
OF THE ONE OF WHICH YOU ARE NOW
THE DIRECTOR?
IN OTHER WORDS, DIRECTOR RAY,
ARE YOU GOING TO DO ANYTHING TO
RESTORE THE REPUTATION OF THIS
OF THE WORLD’S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT INSTITUTION, OR
ARE YOU GOING TO SWEEP IT UNDER
THE RUG, BEING AN
INSTITUTIONALIST AND AFRAID TO
ROCK THE VOTE TO MAYBE YOU WANT
TO PROTECT YOUR FRIENDS AND YOU
DON’T WANT TO GO THERE.
WELL FOR THE SAKE OF THE 99% OF
GREAT AGENTS, THAT IS MY FBI PEN
RIGHT THERE.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE COUNTRY, THE RULE
OF LAW, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THE FBI AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
IF YOU ARE NOT UP TO THE JOB,
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TELL
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I’M NOT UP TO
THIS JOB.
I DON’T WANT TO DO THE HEAVY
LIFTING HERE.
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE GENERAL FLYNN
THE NEW DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
ADD INSULT TO INJURY, THE JUDGE
PRESIDING OVER FLYNN’S CASE,
EMMET SULLIVAN, HE DID A GREAT
JOB AND TED STEVENS CASE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT HAS GOTTEN
INTO HIM.
HE SEEMS DETERMINED TO DRAG THE
GENERAL THROUGH THE MUD ALL OVER
AGAIN TO ONCE ACCUSING HIM OF
TREASON.
ANTS THE DEFENSE AGREED TO DROP
ALL OF THE CHARGES AND END
THIS CASE COMMIT JUDGE SULLIVAN
INVITED LIBERAL GROUPS TO SUBMIT
AN AN AMICUS PRIEST, AND ARGUE
IN FAVOR OF CONTINUING FLYNN’S
PERSECUTION.
BREAKING TODAY, AN ATTORNEY SAID
AN EMERGENCY APPEAL TO REMOVE
JUDGE SULLIVAN FROM THIS CASE.
HE NEEDS TO GO.
HE IS RIGHTLY ARGUING THAT THE
JUDGE IS ABUSING HIS POWER,
PARTICULARLY SINCE THE JUDGE
ACCUSED FLYNN OF BEING A TRAITOR
TO THE U.S.
NICE WAY TO TREAT PEOPLE.
NOW SADLY TONIGHT, WHAT HAPPENED
TO GENERAL FLYNN, AS HORRIBLE AS
IT IS, THAT IS ONLY THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
NOW SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
FOLLOW ME ON THE HEELS OF WHAT
DEVIN NUNES AND TREY GOWDY SAID,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM IS NOW
DEMANDING UNMASKING RECORD
SURMOUNTING MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AND YES,
EVEN THE PRESIDENT’S FAMILY.
TREY GOWDY AND DEVIN NUNES HAS
TOLD US HAPPENED.
SENATOR GRAHAM ALSO JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, THEY WILL
BEGIN THEIR HEARINGS ON JUNE 3RD
ON WHETHER OR NOT TO SUBPOENA
COMEY.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD SUBPOENA
COMEY, McCABE, PETER STRUCK,
LORETTA LYNCH, SALLY YATES,
BRENNAN, CLAPPER, RICE,
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND MANY OTHERS.
SO BUCKLE UP ALL OF YOU
DEEP STATE SABOTEURS THAT ARE
THERE.
THIS WILL BE SUMMER CAMP WITH
YOUR LAWYERS.
YOU WILL HAVE TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WITH THEM IN
AIR-CONDITIONED OFFICES AND I
HOPE YOU LIKE A LOT OF COFFEE,
AND WAGED A INTEL CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
TRANSITION TEAM AND TWO YEARS OF
THE TRUMPS PRESIDENCY.
THEY WILL LIKELY BE FORCED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS UNDER OATH.
BY THE WAY, LYING UNDER OATH IS
A SERIOUS CRIME.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT TELL US
THAT.
BY THE WAY COME ALL THOSE THAT
ABUSE POWER, YOU MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, IF ROGER STONE,
PAUL MANAFORT, >> IF THEY
GET SET UP AND HUNG OUT TO DRY
ON LYING TO CONGRESS AND THEY
GET 29 GUYS AND CUT TACTICAL
GEAR RATING THEIR HOUSE, PREDAWN
RAIDS AT SEA AND IN CAMERAS AND
ONE CASE NO CNN CAMERAS AND THE
OTHER, YOU DESERVE THE SAME
TREATMENT.
WHILE GRAHAM, BILL BARR, DURUM
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL IN HISTORY, DEMOCRATS
ARE TRYING TO REVISE THEIR
IMPEACHMENT REQUEST.
NOW, THEY JUST TOLD THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT THAT THEY NEEDED
THE FULL, UNREDACTED MUELLER
REPORT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEIR IMPEACHMENT
INVESTIGATION IS STILL UNDERWAY.
HANG ON A SECOND.
I THOUGHT THAT THE HOUSE DID THE
IMPEACHMENT, THE SENATE HELD THE
TRIAL AND THE PRESIDENT WAS
FOUND NOT GUILTY.
BY A LONG SHOT.
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO ARGUE TO
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT THAT THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS STILL ONGOING.
OKAY, IT IS OVER!
BUT THEY ARE ALSO SIGNALING THEY
NEVER WANT TO STOP IMPEACHMENTS.